with regard to general Flynn and his
unmasking I think it goes at least up to
Joe Biden Joe Biden we now have
documents that were Declassified
yesterday by Rick Rennell that show the
Joe Biden requested the unmasking of
general Flynn I'm Dave Rubin and this is
the Rubin report quick reminder
everybody to subscribe to our Channel
and click that little bell so you get
delivered our videos and more
importantly joining me today is the
junior senator from Kentucky and the
fiercest defender of Liberty that we
have in the United States government
Senator Rand Paul I'm thrilled you're
finally joining us and I'm glad to Dave
all right so let's dive in I think we're
just gonna split this interview I know
you've got about a half hour we're gonna
just split it into two parts let's spend
the first half talking about this FISA
Amendment that you just proposed can you
just talk a little bit about why you did
it what's going on with surveillance I
sense people are seriously confused
about the whole Flynn case what the
Obama administration may or may not have
known so if you could just kind of do a
101 to clean up some of that that would
be great
well the FISA Court is the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court and it
was set up in the 70s basically to
investigate spy on survey all foreigners
and possible terrorists it was never
intended really to be used against
political candidate candidates or to
investigate American political campaigns
or American political figures but does
everybody know this is what the the
secret court that they used to go after
President Trump in 2016 in the summer
and the fall
and I think this was a horrendous abuse
of power and using a secret court to go
after an American I think is a travesty
of justice so this is a court that lacks
constitutional protections when you go
to a regular court a constitutional
court that was established by article 3
of the Constitution you get over layer
that's one obvious thing you get but you
also get the Fourth Amendment the Fourth
Amendment says that they can't search
your house or your phone or any of these
things
let's they go to a judge and they have
to say that there's probable cause that
you committed a crime it's a it's a
fairly high standard but it's the
constitutional standard in the miser
Court they go to it and they say well
you have to have probable cause that we
think you are associated with the
foreign government so that's what they
do in Carter page they said oh we see
you've talked to the Russians and he
said well yeah I told the CIA I'm you
know I've run into Russians I do
business I'm in these think tanks and I
I told the CIA and they know that I've
talked to the Russians before not tried
to give them information they discounted
all that lied to the FISA Court and then
what began this whole Trump
investigation but here's my point
a lot of Republicans a lot of
conservatives a lot of libertarians are
upset how do you fix it one way of doing
it is to try to make the FISA Court
system more like a constitutional court
so add protections and the scheme of
things but here's my point I don't think
it's possible to make it constitutional
they don't notify you that they're
investigating you so it's secret you
don't get a lawyer some of the reforms
are to give you a friend
amicus so somebody a friend of the court
that argue straight but they still don't
tell you you've been accused of anything
you don't really direct a lawyer to
direct your defense and so I don't think
it fixes a system so my amendment would
simply say this the FISA Court really
isn't constitutional for Americans so
let's exempt Americans from it
and let's use it only on foreigners it
is you know for all it's called the
foreign intelligence court why don't we
go after foreigners with it and people
say well what if what if there really
was a spy in a political campaign what
would you do well use the Constitution
go to a judge ask for a warrant to
search the person or just surveil the
person and judges do grab things like
that but you have to have evidence but
you'd also have to obey the Bill of
Rights and the Fourth Amendment that's
where I'm for but unfortunately I'm in
the minority up here I think that would
win with your crowd watching yeah but
I'm afraid it probably it didn't have
enough votes in the Senate to win yeah
well I assure you you're doing just fine
in the majority on my audience and we've
got some work to do there so can you
just clarify a little bit it seems that
sort of right-leaning Twitter let's call
right now he's saying that this stuff
really went up the chain of command and
it's possible now that Biden and or
Obama themselves actually knew about it
and were were instigating some of this
stuff what's the actual evidence at this
point well with regard to general Flynn
and his unmasking I think it goes at
least up to Joe Biden Joe Biden we now
have documents that were Declassified
yesterday by Rick Rennell that show that
Joe Biden requested the unmasking of
general Flynn what does that mean they
get like a national security or a FISA
warrant to listen to the phone call of
the Russian ambassador I can kind of
understand that we spy on ambassadors
they spy on us next what goes on around
the world but if that ambassador is
talking to a person who's elected to our
government or part of the administration
like general Flynn they're supposed to
say oh no he's talking to an American
we're not supposed to listen or if we
listen we're not supposed to unmask that
person well the thing is if you're a
prominent person a lot of people know
you by your voice and you may want
introduce yourself by saying mr.
ambassador this is general Flynn so it's
kind of it's hard to really completely
mask it but here's the point you're only
supposed to unmask that person if
there's a national security reason so if
they're plotting to attack the US you'd
say well that's reasonable you hadn't
asked them to try to stop the plot with
they're discussing policy and the person
is the national security adviser there
would be absolutely no reason other than
a politically motivated one so this is
politically motivated that it becomes
illegal surveillance illegal
eavesdropping and really you remember we
have this impeachment trial over them
saying someone in government used
government to go after a political
opponent turns out what they did to
general Flynn sounds exactly like that
they abused government they used
surveillance to go after their political
opponent are you worried for for a
limited government guy you don't want
the administrative state to be too big
it's like you can get in the weeds on
all of this stuff but in many ways this
is what you've spent your whole life
fighting that people that the whole
system has just gotten so big and crazy
at this point that even if you tell
well what's true and we have all the
facts in front of us that sort of the
ship has sailed
on on reining in the things that I think
you and I and most of my audience are
worried about yes and no I think if you
ask your audience obviously it's
probably a very limited government
audience but even if you're asked a
general audience so for example if I ask
everybody in Kentucky about whether or
not a secret court where you don't get a
lawyer should investigate political
campaigns how much that falls at 75% but
you can keep Trump out of it no Trump's
pretty popular in my state so it doesn't
hurt so much but really if you could get
Trump out of it but the problem is
people get they won't vote on principle
and idea so I didn't get any Democrat
votes on this I only got 11 Republicans
but I got o Democrats even though many
of them professed to think that FISA has
too much power and shouldn't be
investigating Americans who wouldn't
vote for it because they saw it as a
vote rebuking FISA over Trump and so
they saw it as a political vote but I
guess I don't look at it this way I lose
a lot of time I'm and I'm used to losing
on votes in the Senate but I think most
of this in this is where we do have some
ability so we pass out a sheet of
prominent tweets that went out from
senators each each week on Wednesday and
while my office does this sheet and they
all complain because we'll put out
something in my tweet Oh have gotten
thirty thousand retweets and then we'll
put out senator so-and-so they got six
so right things they see is that the
Liberty movement has reach well beyond
them and they fear the electorate these
people are afraid of elections they're
afraid of me they're afraid of
conservatives because they're afraid
someday someone's gonna wake up and
challenge them in the primary and that's
what has to happen the Democrats it's
sort of like this Democrats don't care
at all about the deficit and they'll
tell you and they want to spend more
money they're honest about it
Republicans say they're against at say
they're against spending but they're
also most of them big government
Republicans vote lockstep with the
Democrats only when people ask me whose
fault is it Republican or Democrat I say
yeah you know it's really party's fault
but you know we could give up and just
protect ourselves but you know I think
if we give up and the few good voices
here go away then really I think it goes
much quicker for socialism it goes much
quicker towards indebtedness and big
government so has to be some voices it
needs to be more the newer people up
here I think are frankly better than you
know the ones that have been here a long
time so I have good conversations with
senator Braun senator Rick Scott from
Florida and who I think are open to you
know I'm you know I'm to both you know
ice amendment Mike Lee order with me on
the FISA Amendment also can you talk a
little bit about your relationship with
Trump because one of the things that
I've said to my audience repeatedly is
first off I should tell you you'll
appreciate this I voted for Gary Johnson
I'm here in California and I had the
luxury of you know doing a third party
situation which obviously certain people
depending on where you live you didn't
have the luxury of doing that but I
wanted to make a vote for Liberty more
than anything else but one of the
reasons that I've become more okay with
Trump over the last couple years is that
the guy that I respect most in the
Senate you has become one of his big
allies and my feeling was well if Rand
Paul who I aligned with on so much of
the Liberty stuff sees something in him
that he can work with then I view that
as a net good can you talk about I a
little bit about your relationship
personally but also just what do you
think his actual governing principles
are because it's hard to say they're
traditionally conservative or republican
or whatever else he doesn't come from a
steeped developed generosity of
libertarianism however when you talk to
him about warm and he talks about the
Iraq war he gets it more than any other
Republican obviously other than my dad
or myself or Mike Lee he gets it and he
says the Iraq war was a mistake he was
unafraid to criticize the bushes for
making what he said was the biggest
foreign policy blunder over the last few
decades and he's right about that and if
you talk to him he'll tell you
consistently wants to bring the troops
home from Afghanistan he wants to end
the war but here's the problem is it is
a tug of war I try to influence and
really I don't think you can
I think you can tug at their instincts
and try to bring them in a direction
they may already believe in and I think
he already does believe those things the
hard part is he's been surrounded often
and many of his appointees have been
people with opposite opinion of ours but
also opposite opinion the president's
john bolton was a disaster john bolton
sort of is the antithesis of
libertarianism you know he's a big
spending hog and never met a war he
didn't like and never met a simple civil
liberty who wouldn't trampled and yet he
got picked and was on the inside but he
was there everyday and I'm talking to
the president once a week so I'm at a
disadvantage Lindsey Graham's on that
same side as well so we you know he's
pushing one way we're pushing the other
but I can tell you in private when it's
the president I and Lindsey Graham he'll
often rebuke if not always rebuked
Graham for being for so much war and
being for perpetual war all that being
said libertarians limited government
people people want less war who are
conservatives all get frustrated it's
like how can we got about the same
amount of troops again more troops in
Saudi Arabia but also look at it this
way it's always a balance of how of what
it could be so for example the conflict
with Iran had you had Lindsey Graham as
president during that and we would have
blown up Iran we would have had a whole
war we may well have had regime change
and people say ought to be good well but
it could be chaos and it could be
another 10 or 15 years of chaos in that
region so I think the President does
show restraint you know they shot a
drone down you know of course they said
they didn't but I mean all evidence
pointing to us I'm shooting a drone down
and the president showed restraint
he said well nobody was killed and the
they were encouraging me everybody
wanted me to attack around it was gonna
be limited but we're gonna kill I don't
know 150 or 450 or something he just
said you know we're just not gonna do it
and I think there's a great there's
statesmanship and restraint and I think
he shows that I think his instincts are
good on war and I think libertarians who
decide you know I want to effect the
election I might as a battleground state
I think should look for things like that
is he a perfect libertarian now he
doesn't seem to be too concerned with
dad or really the size and scope of
government
much as many of us would wish but on war
he has some instincts towards less war
less intervention on money we spend
overseas and international agencies and
all this stuff when we give up our
sovereignty and these international
agencies you know blast us and and
harangue us and tell us how evil we are
while cashing our checks that thanks for
all that their salaries he's very good
on understanding that and thinking that
other people need to pay their fair
share and so there's a lot to be said
that's good and then you know it is
always we're all you know I tell people
if you want the perfect candidate
run for office yourself otherwise
they're always picking and choosing and
trying to find the best that you can
find yeah so all right let's shift a
little bit towards Corona and stimulus
and just what's happening broadly I'm
finding right now that there actually is
a really nice moment for liberty minded
people because one of the things that
we're suddenly talking about in America
that we never talked about or when I go
to libertarian conferences they talk
about it but nobody else talks about it
it states rights that is actually
something being discussed at a national
level right now I think people are
realizing they should be able to protect
their family so talking about the Second
Amendment I think people are realizing
that maybe they don't want to be in
giant cities anymore in I sense we're
gonna have some really interesting
population things changing do you sense
that because of coronavirus that the the
Liberty movement and people realizing
that your your congressman and your
senator are way more important or should
be way more important to your life than
your president or are you hopeful that
something might crack here I mean I'm
even seeing lefties say we should lower
taxes on people now because they need
more money in their pockets
well you're optimistic and I'm glad
you're optimistic on it I would say this
I would say one of the lessons we can
and should learn from the way government
responds to this virus is that one size
doesn't fit all and that would go along
with federalism and that will go along
with really you should try to devolve to
the smallest governmental unit and
really beyond that you know the ninth
amendment says the rights not listed or
not to be disparage but they're to be
left to the states and the people it's
important it's not just state
governments because state governments
can be tyrannical as well we're really
and the people the problem we have is
even though we have devolved most of
most of trumps pronouncements even the
ones that have been restrictive have
been guidelines without penalties most
of the penalties and most of the
punishment mostly absolute shut down the
economy came from governors so even
though I did devolve the state's the
states with draconian my state including
my mic my governor's you know just I
call in DWP drunk with power the guys
intoxicated with his own power but
here's what happened in our state the
legislature who knows when years ago
passed an emergency action bill and said
the governor gets it during an emergency
and I think he even gets to declare the
emergency well you know there's no
check-in balance our legislature can't
call themselves back in session we have
a majority of Republican legislature
they have no say
the governor has become essentially the
sole and unique and all-powerful person
that dictates everything about the
economy he closed everything down and
he's still saying things like well we're
not gonna have childcare open up until
we get a vaccine it's like really so
working parents aren't going back what
if we never get a vaccine
he banned church he banned to interstate
travel the court struck him down on both
of those but he keeps on going and he
acts as if he's you know he's really out
there to try to help save the people
we've had a little bit over 300 deaths
and that's sad if it was somebody in
your family but that really the number
of deaths in Kentucky closely mirrored
the flu from before I'm not saying this
is the traditional flu but I am saying
in certain states the outcome has not
been worse than the flu the other thing
about one size
it's all that we need to recognize is
young people have almost a zero
mortality to this zero to 18 almost zero
less than the flu they don't want to
hear it but zero to 18 deaths among
children is less than the blue flu is
more deadly now if it goes up it's the
opposite when you get to 70 and 80
particularly you're 80 and above and you
are in a nursing home it might be 20 or
25 percent mortality which is you know
50 times worse than the flu so but that
means maybe we should have a different
strategy for the kids throwing out for
who the elderly and maybe we didn't have
to close the economy down maybe we could
have done what Sweden did and not close
the schools down we have still have
knuckleheads like my governor who wanted
to keep schools closed in the fall it's
a disaster the economy can't function
many people work with their kids in
school that's where their kids go to you
know it's it's a form of a place for
kids to go while the parents work and so
we've got to open the schools but that's
the biggest thing we have to do and
you're right some of it devolves back to
States and we should want more but
really we shouldn't stop the devolution
of power with the governor we got to go
to the cities mayors and really
ultimately if you own your business it's
your business and you're gonna have to
respond to public pressure I don't have
to tell you what to do
if you run a risk and you say I'm gonna
do nothing you're gonna get some people
like me who have already had it would
love to come to your restaurant but a
lot of people gonna be worried you're
gonna have to do other things you have
to have a senior citizens section you
may have to have some spacing but if the
government mandates it they'll be idiots
they'll tell everybody is six six week
apart and if I've got five kids I don't
need to socially distance for my kids we
should all sit at one table on top of
each other you know but if the
government mandates it they're gonna do
ridiculous things businesses will figure
this out churches will figure this out
you know if your mother is 85 years old
and she lives in a small town and 20
people go to her church and they'll you
know spaced out in the church since she
wants to go by golly let her go but if
your mother's 85 years old and she used
to a mega church with 2,000 people
crammed into the pews
I wouldn't mandate that she not go but
if she were my mother I would tell her
not to go mean so we were not stupid we
we should let people
make decisions on risk yeah so Reda
mentioned nah you mentioned knuckleheads
and I'm here in California as you may
know so I've got gavin newsom as my
governor and I've got Eric Garcetti as
my mayor here in LA these are big
government progressive so I'm gonna ask
you for a little life advice right now
for the first time since I moved to LA I
love it here it's 85 and sunny every day
my life has thrived I've got a great
small business I'm in my garage right
now senator it's pretty sweet but I am
honestly thinking about leaving because
I I don't know I don't trust that these
people will make the right decisions and
I wonder just generally what's your
philosophy on if because I think a lot
of people are seeing this right now if
they live in a state that there'll oh
they're officials ideas are totally
incongruent with their beliefs do you
generally believe in stay and fight or
do you would you say no you can get on
over to Kentucky get on over to Florida
get on over to Texas and you know go
where maybe your ideas are more in line
because I think this is like the most
unspoken thing in America right now my
family you know lives in Texas and I
grew up in Texas and I'll tell you what
they tell me about Californians you can
come you didn't bring your oh no you can
participate in the economy of Texas but
leave all those stupid political ideas
of the majority in California in
California so that's not you but they
worry so many Californians come
complaining about high taxes and then
they come and they vote for high taxes
in Texas but Texas is kicking butts
those Nevada I mean all the states that
have low or no income tax you know look
at the like of professional golfers like
Mickelson remember they gave him such a
hard time and then I think you finally
did quietly Levy says well I'm not
leaving any finally yet I mean you're
you're a fool if you're making high-end
I know California is beautiful but they
take all your income and they're gonna
probably keep you in your garage forever
you know your beers gonna turn out it
already is turning great baby you're
gonna go agree there I let you know you
know yeah
all right so I think you're telling me
to get going I've got a lot of invites
I'm trying to get Ted Cruz to officially
give me some sort of package to get me
there so will
we know what happens when you do so
beautiful the coast and the mountains
and all of that it's just an amazing
state so I love one out there and it's
like except for your legislature and the
craziness you've got you get so much so
many problems I don't even now you exist
in fact you're a good example of how
resilient capitalism is despite having a
bunch of the best word is knuckleheads
socialist government planners running
you're running your cities and yet
somehow you know California still has so
much going on with the great climate for
agriculture the great coastline for
tourism so you know we'll see but I
think there is a there's a chronic
exodus from you know New York California
I'll give you an example of what rick
scott told us the other day you know the
form of governor of florida and now a
senator he said florida has three
million more people than new york state
but has one half the state budget this
is another reason not to send these
people more bailout money because
they've just wasted and will just reward
bad behavior they also will never open
the economy if we pass this democrat
latest one in addition to all the other
bailouts do you think they're more or
less likely to open their economy would
give them money
no the only reason these people will
open their economies when they run out
of other people's money and so that's
coming their their state Treasuries over
there and they're gonna have to
eventually open up even though they love
controlling you and telling you what to
do they're gonna finally become
frightened when there's no money to even
pay their own salaries yeah all right
senator I know you're crunched for time
so I just have one more for you can you
just lay out sort of the the broad sort
of libertarian approach when it comes to
helping people that need help most and
stimulus packages and everything else
this is where I see libertarians get hit
all the time and don't necessarily have
a good comeback when we see 30 million
people unemployed and we don't we don't
have the money to bail everything out
yet we always do it and get further into
debt and you're basically the only guy
in the Senate talking about it what is
the proper or better than proper what is
the responsible approach to helping
people when we're telling them that they
can't work yet also knowing that we
don't even have the money in the first
place
I think the most humanitarian economic
system is capitalism it creates enormous
amounts of wealth and that's how you can
help those who can't help themselves is
by having great and enormous amounts of
wealth created socialism doesn't work I
mean if you think you're gonna be a
humanitarian
you know elect Chavez oh that's right
you already have in California but I
mean we think yeah really think over it
don't rub it it's not gonna work
socialism doesn't work capitalism is
humanitarian and then the only other
thing to remember is is that don't let
people guilt you into anything look I
feel an obligation to my fellow man and
most people too I feel an obligation I
want to live in a community where there
are not people in the streets hungry and
begging I want people to be taken care
of my wife and I participated several
different charities in our community we
try to help raise money for them and we
want there to be a place for people with
addiction for people getting out of
prison and trying to get a skill all
those things are we actually want them
for a selfish reason because we want to
live in a community John Allison is good
at describing this and saying you know
he's big United Way because he wants to
live in a community where there aren't
four people everywhere that are begging
and and on the streets he wants a
community where there is charity that
takes care of them and we shouldn't be
embarassed to that that there's a
selfish reason to give charity sort of
an I'm Randy and sort of you know
self-interest in altruism actually but
the other thing is is that we should
remember that there's a difference
between an obligation and a right so I
have an obligation to help my fellow man
because of my religious and moral
beliefs but you don't have a right to a
penny from him and Bernie Sanders does
not have a right to conscript me and
make me give my services to somebody who
it doesn't have any money as a physician
I do give my services so but we just
can't you know once we give in and say
oh they have a right to our services
then we're all slaves and we shouldn't
do it and I've had this fight with
Bernie before and it's a good YouTube
clip of he and I going back and forth in
committee and but we shouldn't give Ben
on these things we've got to keep
fighting even though we don't always win
I think there's a much broader audience
out there than there is in Washington we
just got to replace a few people if
you'll help me
replace a few people it'll be a lot
better I'm with you man well I really
appreciate it I wish we had more time
but I know you you've got actual work to
do so get to fix in the whole system
and I hope we can do this in person at
some point all right thank you if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell